this book is right along my alley a pimp
Fox who normally host this show is twice
the man I am but smaller man than me but
he does this this standing desk thing
what you just built on his own because
he couldn't get you know he couldn't
wait to get the right monitors installed
and everything should people do that so
people get up we have I take we've been
finding this tens of thousands of people
are getting up the the dangers of
sitting with respect to the chronic
diseases you mentioned but in on top of
that sort of the mental slowing that
people feel stultified at their desks
every day people are getting up across
America across the world Cory and so
what we're finding that as people get up
particularly working corporations is
their productivity improves they're more
alert more creative and so what I've
come to notice is that things are just
getting better and better the more and
more people get up yeah so specifically
the health things tell me about the
health risks and why they happen in the
body you're a doctor
34 chronic diseases many of which you
mentioned but including cancer and
depression on top of the diabetes and
obesity of course why but why just cuz
your legs are folded and yes in the
crunch today no no that is precisely
right as soon as you crunch somebody
down the huge genetic molecular elements
that support the body and run the
metabolism gets slowed and it is simply
an unnatural position for the human body
to be an hour upon hour upon hour and in
so doing the cholesterol rises the blood
sugar Rises toxins are not cleared and
then all of those negative health
consequences results now I took up in
earnest I've always worked out a lot of
lift waiters
I took up walking uh-huh just walking
not running I do some running as well
but the simple I would swim and stuff
I burned when I started walking 10,000
steps a day changed my diet was a little
bit less sugar I lost 30 pounds in about
a year and it was simply amazing to me
for me the inspiration was a pedometer
of my wrist of the jawbone up is the one
I'm wearing right now but I keep hearing
stories like mine for lots of people
when they just start standing I mean I
literally heard before I left Phoenix to
come here a 300-pound gentleman said all
I've started doing is walking to work
300-pound gentleman lost
five pounds in six months your story
will live 15 miles away in Phoenix where
so long it's a long walk to New York but
but but this idea just as you said it is
introducing walking into your day
displacing sitting activities for active
ones people lose 10 20 30 40 pounds a
year is quite impressive and all without
breaking a sweat and what a deal that is
why did people start sitting I think
we've been sitting in the way that we do
sit right I think since the Industrial
Revolution in fact we became seduced in
the 1940s evolved the modern office
space where we were entrained to be
stuck at our desks and then the managers
got the sense that if you see people
moving around the office they can't be
walking that can't be good and so
they're in evolve the modern office and
all of us who are stuck behind monitors
answering endless worthless emails hours
upon hours upon hours realize how
entrapped we've become and then of
course we get in our cars and go home
and then we're in front of the TV and
internet during the evening and all of a
sudden you spent 15 hours on your bottom
and it's just not what we're meant to do
now as it relates to the workplace you
know we had some great American great
Michigan corporations like Herman Miller
and Steelcase of course that really
designed the way we work right um they
probably think that they're succumbing
to customers more but I would argue that
they've had a great role in making the
way that we work work what are they
doing to this movement of standing and
what are they doing in terms of
designing the furniture again so credit
where credit is due
so when Steelcase saw these data coming
out of the scientific laboratories they
realized that there would be an implicit
need across corporate America to give
people not boxes that they're adding up
to this but proper industrial grade
professional solutions and Steelcase
actually developed the treadmill desk
and there's a with me and and and our
team at Mayo and this has been the most
phenomenally successful enterprise not
just for those 10 20 30 40 50 thousand
people who've actually purchased them
from multiple companies now but also for
getting the idea out the idea that you
can walk and work I mean you just think
of a standard conference call where
you're sitting on your bottom and you
know you just have daydreaming or doing
eBay whatever it is one does if one can
just be walking at perhaps one one and a
half two miles an hour doing that call
learn 150 calories once actually more
attentive to those types of calls those
kind of interactions and that is what
the treadmill desk scenario has taught
us that people can walk sometimes for
two three four hours whilst at work be
healthier lose the 40 or 50 pounds I was
particularly inspired there's this thing
going on in Silicon Valley where you
know Steve Jobs would do this but Mark
Zuckerberg does as famously walks around
the campus Jeff Weiner LinkedIn walks
around the campus I'm not one of those
guys but I don't do meetings and
conference rooms anymore I can't look at
PowerPoint slides everywhere again if
someone brings a deck does show me makes
my eyes glaze over we go for walks down
the Embarcadero in San Francisco and
it's changed the dynamic strange right
people answer questions differently that
the number retention might not be the
same in might but what you talk about
the way you talk about it's really
different
so we've why we've introduced walking
talk meetings about more than 70 US
corporations the dynamic is different
it's sort of like you know if you have a
bad day in what's what how do you deal
with that one of the best ways of
dealing with having a pat is to take a
friend or a loved one and go for a walk
and there is an intimacy about walking
with somebody is something you're doing
with something it's a it's actually a
very intimate thing to do with somebody
and if you hold a walk and talk meeting
exchanging ideas on the move it's
Socrates came up with the idea this is
nothing new it is such a powerful way of
interacting with somebody and so much
more healthy and therefore more positive
and you're getting that buzz I believe
as one's walking that positivity and
that endorphin buzz what a combination
creativity and work Annie Kuster we mean
I take people I don't like when I
halfway through my walk we go up the
filbert steps it's about 400 EPS of
decoite hour it's cruel and punishing